Flies and mosquitoes can be a nuisance around the home.
So here's a quick tip on how to create an effective trap...
...using household ingredients and a plastic water bottle.
First, you wanna cut off the top of your water bottle.
Then you invert the top and tape the two pieces together.
Next, you wanna add simple syrup made from equal parts sugar and water,...
...leaving about an inch between the spout and the fluid.
Insects will travel inside and get caught in the liquid.
For an even stronger attractant, use a solution of warm water, sugar, and yeast...
...which creates more carbon dioxide and works really well with mosquitoes.
If you have an effective liquid bait that you use,...
...we'd love to hear about it in the comments below.